[Música]
el ejército de Israel mató a tres
jóvenes palestinos en cisjordania
ocupada en el año más mortífero para los
palestinos de los territorios ocupados y
en el día internacional de solidaridad
con el pueblo palestino cuando se
cumplen 75 años de la resolución de la
ONU que contemplaba la creación de un
estado judío y un estado árabe en
palestino
jornada cargada de diplomacia en torno a
la guerra en Ucrania dos cumbres de alto
nivel debaten la invasión rusa reunida
en Rumanía la otan mantiene su apoyo a
kiev y en Alemania miembros del g7
condenan los crímenes de guerra en
territorio ucraniano Tenemos reporte
desde Berlín
en Estados Unidos la Corte Suprema
revisa el orden de prioridades de
deportación decretado por la
administración biden que se centra en
las personas culpables de crímenes
graves El Ejecutivo demócrata cambió lo
estipulado por Donald Trump y
gobernadores republicanos han llevado
Este cambio ante los tribunales
ampliamos desde Washington
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
hoy 29 de noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional de solidaridad con el
pueblo de Palestina hace 75 años la
asamblea general de las Naciones Unidas
aprobó la resolución que estipulaba la
creación de un estado judío y un estado
árabe en Palestina El Aniversario llega
en un momento de recrudecimiento del
conflicto derivado de la ocupación
israelí de hecho hoy el ejército de
Israel ha matado a tres jóvenes
palestinos cerca de ramalá este 2022
está siendo el año más mortífero para
los palestinos de los territorios
ocupados un escenario que se complica
ante la inminente investidura del
gobierno ultraderechista y Ultra
ortodoxo de Israel liderado por Benjamín
netanyahu conectamos ahora con el
politólogo Ezequiel Coppel para analizar
la situación Ezequiel 75 años después de
esta resolución el secretario general de
Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez
mantiene el discurso de los dos estados
una medida defendida públicamente en
varias ocasiones también por Joe biden
si bien públicamente no haya ningún
proceso de diálogos abierto considera
posible todavía la creación de un estado
palestino
a ver yo creo que en el deseo de los
palestinos está todavía la idea de crear
un estado palestino ahora en la práctica
o en el terreno la idea de crear un
estado un estado contigo palestino Es
realmente casi imposible es decir el
territorio de si Jordania donde prevé un
estado palestino junto a la franca de
gas el territorio está de alguna manera
perforado como un queso gruyere con
cerca de cientos 120 asentamientos
legales es decir que el estado Israel lo
reconoce y otros 100 asentamientos
ilegales es un punto interesante pensar
que el nuevo líder de extrema derecha
que participa en la nueva colección
israelí es habitante unos asentamientos
yo creo que en Israel lo que está
pasando Es que
año año los ciudadanos israelíes Los
Reales israelíes votan a candidatos que
no están a favor de los estados
y precisamente no está ocupación ilegal
de territorios palestinos el bloqueo de
gaza es denunciado tanto por Naciones
Unidas como por ongs internacionales
porque la comunidad internacional no
impone sanciones e incluso ciertos
países como Estados Unidos apoyan a
militarmente económicamente a Israel
creo que es complicado Yo creo que es
verdad mucha gente marca como una
especie de doble moral del mundo con
respecto al conflicto horario y
palestino y nombran que por ejemplo el
mundo está Unido contra la ocupación
rusa de Ucrania pero no así con la
contracupación que ya llega más de medio
siglo y raíz sobre si Jordania es
complicado yo creo que
gran parte de lo que se denomina las
bará israelí lo que es parte de lo que
es relaciones públicas israelíes o
propaganda israelí asocia el conflicto a
una especie de odio milenario de los
áreas de los judíos cuando especialmente
es un poquito territorial Yo creo que
esa idea esa idea de propaganda ha
penetrado por otro lado también me
gustaría decir que hasta el día de hoy a
pesar de que Estados Unidos no ha
demostrado haber sido un mediador justo
porque siempre ha inclinado un poco la
balanza hacia el lado israelí es el
único mediador que de alguna manera
puede convencerlos y realidad de hacer
algo es decir muchas veces se dice que
Estados Unidos tiene que salir del papel
creador porque no es justo porque tira
más para el lado israelí que para el
lado palestino pero lo interesante es
pensar que si entraría otro mediador
como Rusia como china directamente no
tendría ninguna posibilidad de
presionarlos y realidad y precisamente
crea que en lo que queda de
administración vaiden puede haber algún
Avance en algunos diálogos
no son para nada optimistas yo creo que
lo que se está discutiendo en este
momento en la administración biden Es
tratar que cuál es tu nuevo gobierno
israelí es tratar de que no entres en
llamas es decir que el territorio no
entren llamas en lo que está discutiendo
en este momento en las habitaciones
vaiden es tratar de que este nuevo
gobierno donde un componente fuerte es
la extrema derecha israelí un extrema
derecha y Rally que si no piensas acerca
de 30 años había sido expulsado del
parlamento es decir lo que trata de
hacer es que no entren fuego al
territorio y aparece que el punto clave
para pensarlo que no tiene que entrar en
fuego es Jerusalén el tema es que
Jerusalén no se vaya de las manos
Ezequiel Coppel se nos acaba el tiempo
desafortunadamente para abordar este
tema es sin duda muy complejo pero
muchísimas gracias por su análisis No
gracias a usted por la invitación
y hoy es una jornada cargada de
diplomacia en torno a la Guerra de
Ucrania por un lado la Cumbre de los
ministros de exteriores de países
miembros de la otan en bucarest rumania
ha girado en torno al envío a kiev de
más ayuda militar y de asistencia para
reconstruir la infraestructura devastada
por otro lado los ministros de Justicia
del g7 se encontraron en Alemania
algunos de los miembros del grupo de las
siete potencias mundiales entre las que
se cuenta también Rusia condenaron los
crímenes de guerra cometidos en
territorio ucraniano nuestro
corresponsal en Berlín Thomas Sparrow
nos amplía
la ayuda que recibe Ucrania de parte de
los países del g7 y muy de manera
particular de parte de Alemania que este
año preside el grupo no se limita
solamente a la cooperación política a la
ayuda económica o incluso al envío de
armamento también como quedó claro en
una reunión de los ministros de Justicia
del eje 7 realizada en Alemania esa
cooperación con Ucrania se extenderá a
la investigación de posibles crímenes de
guerra cometidos por las fuerzas
militares rusas como parte de su
invasión de Ucrania como explicaron los
ministros de Justicia que atendieron
esta reunión esa cooperación se
extenderá en primer lugar a la
recopilación de pruebas Más allá de
Ucrania en Ucrania ya Hay un
procedimiento en curso para recolectar
pruebas pero esas pruebas también pueden
recolectarse por ejemplo entre los
migrantes entre los refugiados que
dejaron se instalaron por ejemplo en
países como Alemania en Alemania se
estima que alrededor de un millón de
refugiados ucranianos la cooperación
también se refiere a una posible
coordinación entre los diferentes países
del g7 en la recolección de pruebas se
espera que se genere un punto de
contacto en cada uno de los países para
evitar duplicación en la recolección de
información se trata sin duda de un
desafío muy importante de parte del g7
un desafío muy importante también de
parte de Alemania y es un desafío que
puede tardar un buen tiempo en la medida
que los diferentes países Ucrania en
particular pero también los países del
g7 trabajan conjuntamente en la búsqueda
de pruebas para identificar posibles
crímenes de guerra
y el presidente francés Emmanuel macrón
llegará esta noche a Estados Unidos en
su Segunda visita de estado a Washington
donde ya fue invitado en 2018 por Donald
Trump en un contexto internacional
bastante distinto al de Entonces los
mandatarios aliados discutirán
cuestiones que van desde la cooperación
en materia de seguridad hasta las
discrepancias en materia económica
una invitación que es señal de buen
momento entre ambas naciones Emmanuel
Llegará el martes por la noche a
Washington para un viaje de tres días
con mucha pompa Esta visita es la
segunda invitación que recibe maku desde
2018 cuando lo invitó Donald Trump esta
será la primera visita de estado de la
Administración biden Harris pondrá de
relieve la profunda y duradera relación
entre Estados Unidos y Francia nuestro
más antiguo Aliado que se basa en los
valores democráticos que compartimos los
vínculos económicos y la cooperación en
materia de defensa y seguridad la
económica estará en el centro de las
conversaciones la ley de reducción de la
inflación firmada por el presidente
biden preocupa a Europa que denuncia el
proteccionismo estadounidense París
esperar limitar las medidas destinadas a
repatriar a Estados Unidos las
inversiones industriales vinculadas con
la transición energética los temas
espaciales y nucleares también serán
tratados la última etapa del viaje será
Nueva Orleans la ciudad fundada por el
francés
donde se hablara de la francofonía el
encuentro diplomático también contará
con una escena de estado de centenas de
personas en la cual participará la
delegación francesa compuesta por varios
ministros parlamentarios y
personalidades además de una acogida muy
especial se espera de este viaje que
Manuel McQueen pueda hablar en nombre de
toda la Unión Europea
continuamos en Estados Unidos donde la
Corte Suprema empieza hoy el proceso de
revisión de las prioridades de
deportación de la administración de Joe
biden centradas en expulsar del país a
los extranjeros culpables de crímenes
graves un cambio respecto a la ley
impuesta por Donald Trump que los
gobernadores republicanos de Texas y
Luisiana llevaron ante el tribunal
conectamos ahora con nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez que nos ampliaba previamente
la Corte Suprema de Justicia de mayoría
conservadora empieza hoy a escuchar
argumentos del ejecutivo Es decir de la
administración de Joe biden sobre las
prioridades que tiene la patrulla
fronteriza las los encargados de vigilar
la frontera de Estados Unidos con México
las prioridades que tendrán a la hora de
determinar Quiénes son deportados y
Quienes no eso es lo que se está en este
momento debatiendo y escuchando en la
Corte Suprema de Justicia qué
prioridades van a tener estos agentes
fronterizos a la hora de determinar a
quienes puede demandar inmediatamente o
a quienes le da la oportunidad de pues
tener un proceso de asilo en este país
lo que argumentan los
Joe biden y Alejandro mayor que es el
secretario de seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos es que dada el límite de
recursos que tiene pues se tiene que
enfocar entonces la fuerza pública en
las personas que representan una amenaza
una amenaza para la seguridad de Estados
Unidos Esas son las personas que pues la
patrulla fronteriza y los oficiales de
la frontera tienen que enfocarse para
deportar y no al resto de inmigrantes
Texas y Luisiana sin embargo estados
republicanos pues han apelado y han
contrademandado esta decisión y estos
protocolos de que haya propuesto la
administración de Joe biden diciendo que
lo que quieren ellos es tener la
libertad la discreción de poder
deportar a cualquier persona que no sea
legal en este país Alejandro mallorca
dice que Estados Unidos Simplemente no
tiene los recursos para deportar a más
de 11 millones de indocumentados en este
país y hay que Resaltar que esta
decisión se conocerá en julio del
próximo año
en otras noticias durante dos semanas
las fuerzas iraníes han atacado a los
grupos de la oposición kurda iraní con
sede en Irak Teherán acusa a estos
grupos de orquestrar las protestas
masivas desatadas por la muerte de Max
al mismo tiempo Turquía también ha
intensificado sus ataques contra grupos
kurdos tanto en Irak como en Siria
nuestros corresponsales están en el
kurdistán iraki y han hablado con
civiles afectados por los bombardeos
la ciudad de coya está en calma pero La
amenaza nunca está lejos Irán ataca
regularmente la base del partido
democrático del kurdistán iraní estos
ataques han matado a varios civiles
incluida la esposa embarazada de este
pez merga combatiente armado kurdo
estaba lejos de la base pero
bombardearon justo en medio del
campamento eran viviendas donde vivían
mujeres y niños no estaban armados ni
eran militares herido el mismo en el
ataque se encuentra en un lugar que
quiere mantener en secreto
desde el último ataque de hace una
semana los familiares de los pes mergas
se dispersaron surux de 7 años vivía en
el campamento a menudo dibuja el ataque
a su escuela que fue atacada a finales
de septiembre
Aquí están los misiles que bombardearon
nuestra escuela un misil destrozó
nuestra escuela y los alumnos huyeron no
hay nadie allí desde el ataque no tuve
miedo no soy un niño que tenga miedo
los ataques iraníes no solo afectan a
los civiles vinculados a los grupos
armados el pueblo de armota albergaba a
250 familias casi todas han huido este
domingo los bancos de la Iglesia
Católica permanecieron vacíos y ya no se
celebraron servicios
le gustaría que la situación se
resolviera Y que todos los actores
externos o internos respetarán a esta
nación como a todas las demás en todo el
curdistan iraquí el exasperaciones
similar en el valle de nala aquí el
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán el pkk se enfrenta al ejército
Turco según los informes 15 civiles han
muerto a causa de los ataques aéreos
turcos desde principios de año en el
kurdistán iraquí
se trata de un enfrentamiento entre el
pkk y Turquía en la región Así que
podemos decir que Turquía y el peca acá
son responsables pero el gobierno debe
expulsarlos de esta zona
los pastores ya no pueden cuidar
libremente su ganado en las montañas los
habitantes de aquí se sienten aislados y
abandonados por las autoridades iraquíes
y kurdas
sigan con nosotros
[Música]